good morning welcome to the cato
institute i'm roger pilon i'm the
director of cato's center for
constitutional studies
and
together with the federalist society
we're hosting today's forum i want to
thank the federalist society
dean reuter and julie nix who are with
us today
for their assistance in organizing this
forum
i also want to welcome the those who are
seeing us through c-span
and
our live streaming audience as well
we're here to discuss an important new
uh an important subject uh
the permission society the title of a
new book from encounter books by the
goldwater institute's tim sandefer
subtitled
how the ruling class turns our freedoms
into privileges
and what we can do about it this book
documents the many ways especially since
the progressive era
that the presumption of liberty the
freedom at the heart of our
founding principles and documents has
been extinguished in favor of a
presumption for government
with individuals having to obtain
permission from government officials
before being able to act property owners
have long experienced this reversal of
course
today they often find that before they
can make any changes in their property
they have to obtain a range of permits
from the local zoning zoning board all
the way up to the environmental
protection agency and the u.s army corps
of engineers resulting often
in
extremely huge expenses and lengthy
delays
but it isn't the use of property alone
that the modern permission society
restricts
its speech starting uh starting and
running a business and so much more all
of which tim sanderfer covers in this
important new book our forum today will
discuss this issue in some detail both
pro and khan
i'll introduce each of our speakers
before he speaks starting with tim who
will talk for about 20 to 25 minutes
about the book we'll then have comments
from our two other guests for 10 to 15
minutes each
and then a brief comment from tim
before we
open it up to q a from you in the
audience and then for lunch upstairs in
the georgia m yeager conference center
tim sandifer is vice president for
litigation at the goldwater institute in
phoenix arizona
as i write in the blurb for this new
book
with this his fourth magnificent book
plus countless articles speeches and
legal briefs
tim sanderfer has emerged as one of
america's most important up-and-coming
political and legal theorists a graduate
of hillsdale college in the claremont
the chapman
university school of law tim served for
15 years as a litigator
at the pacific legal foundation before
joining goldwater
at plf he won important victories for
economic liberty in several
states some of which you'll discuss
today
he's the author of four books
cornerstone of liberty property rights
in 21st century america co-authored with
his lovely wife christina which came out
earlier this year
the right to earn a living which came
out in 2010 the conscience of the
constitution in 2014 and now the
permission society plus some 45
scholarly articles on subjects ranging
from eminent domain and economic liberty
to antitrust copyright slavery in the
civil war and political issues in
shakespeare ancient greece greek drama
and star trek
with a range of interests those
accomplishments at such an early age
we're proud to have tim as an adjunct
scholar here at cato please welcome tim
sanderfer
[Applause]
thank you very much it's an honor to be
here and it's kind of hard to see but i
see some old friends out there including
alan guro who's one of the inspirations
for this book
um what came to mind when in some
conversations that alan and some other
friends and i were having was a passage
from james madison 1792 essay charters
madison starts out by saying in europe
charters of liberty have been granted by
power
america has set the example of charters
of power granted by liberty
this revolution in the practice of the
world may with an honest praise be
pronounced the most triumphant epic in
its history
and what madison meant was that unlike
the old doc documents of the of the
english civil war of the glorious
revolution those documents all gave
freedoms to the people or purported to
whereas the american revolution was
founded on the opposite principle that
people are basically free and create the
government through the the their own
agreements through the constitutions and
so forth contrast this for instance
contrast the opening of the declaration
or the constitution with the language of
the magna carta we celebrated the the
anniversary of magna carta last year the
800th anniversary of magna carta but
when you and you know it's a great
document and all that sure but when you
actually read the document it it's
surprising the language that it uses it
says
john by the grace of god king of england
to his loyal subjects greeting to all
free men of our kingdom we have granted
all the liberties written out below
to have and to keep for them and their
and their heirs from us and our heirs so
the magna carta is very clear i the
kingdom giving you the following
freedoms and it lists out those freedoms
that's the opposite of the principles of
the declaration of the or the
constitution that start out by saying
all men are created equal all people are
basically free they then create the
government by an agreement and give it
certain powers most of which are listed
in article 1 section 8 of the
constitution
what the founding fathers did was they
they reversed the older conception of
freedom and they did so on the basis of
a basic principle enunciated by john
locke now this is important i think
because we like we philosophize a lot
about what is freedom is a is a poor
person who is too poor to afford things
really free that sort of argument but i
think those are distractions from what
freedom really is and that is freedom
means not having to ask permission john
locke says freedom is not as we are told
a liberty for every man to do as he
lists for who could be free when every
other man's humor might domineer over
him but instead a liberty to dispose and
order as he lists his person actions
possessions and his whole property
within the allowance of those laws under
which he is and therein not to be
subject to the arbitrary will of another
but to freely follow his own not to have
to ask permission from someone before
using your property or whatever subject
to the same laws that apply to everyone
else
now this was a revolutionary idea in the
1770s because the pri the older model of
freedom was this magna carta principle
that we we tend to call this principle
in the law prior restraint
prior restraint was the old rule when it
came to freedom of press we that's where
we normally hear this term is when we're
talking about freedom of press prior
restraint was the rule that said you had
to get the government's permission
before you could publish something
and in the 17th century this was
overturned and it became the pride of
british subjects that no prior restraint
could be placed on a person before that
person published his sentiments or gave
a speech or something like that might be
punished afterwards if he committed
slander or threats or something like
that but he couldn't be required to ask
permission before uttering his views
but the same principle applies across
the board religion in particular is the
model that i use in the book
under the british system the british
like if you read william blackstone in
his commentaries in the 1760s blackstone
is very proud that british subjects
enjoyed more religious toleration than
the people of any other nation he's very
proud of this and rightly so because
he's right he says in the commentaries
why we even let catholics own property
which was pretty liberal by the
standards of that day right
but the principle behind the british
system was toleration once again the
king was tolerating religious
differences giving religious liberty to
the not liberty but toleration to the
people the founders repudiated this
concept
thomas paine says toleration is not the
opposite of intoleration but is the
counterfeit of it
both are despotisms the one assumes to
itself the right of withholding the
liberty of conscience and the other of
granting it one is the pope armed with
fire and stake the other is the pope
selling or granting indulgences
jefferson says the same thing in notes
on virginia when he's talking about his
proposal for the what became the
virginia statute for religious freedom
he says our rulers can only have such
authority over us as we have submitted
to them
the rights of conscience we have never
submitted we are answerable for them to
god the legitimate powers of government
extend only to such acts as our
injurious to others but it does mean no
injury for my neighbor to say there is
no god or twenty gods it neither picks
my pocket nor breaks my leg
probably my favorite jefferson quote it
neither picks my pocket nor breaks my
leg so it's none of the government's
business
madison in his old age james madison was
very proud and he wrote a little memoir
where he told this story that when he
was young in his 20s he served on the
committee that drafted the virginia
declaration of rights and the primary
figure on the committee was george mason
the respected elder statesman of
virginia politics and mason in his
original draft wrote that all people
would enjoy the total toleration of
religion and madison this then
basically unknown young upstart and this
this intern jumps up and says no no you
can't use the word toleration you must
use the word liberty and he persuaded
mason to replace the word he was very
proud of that
what the founders did here and elsewhere
was to embrace the presumption that we
are all basically free
not that we are basically unfree until
the government gives it to us and that's
reflected in the text of the
constitution which speaks of securing
the blessings of liberty that says that
our rights shall not be abridged that
says no ris no law respecting the
freedom of speech or whatever shall be
passed the right of the people to do so
and so shall not be infringed and of
course the ninth amendment which makes
clear that the list of rights is not
exclusive just because it's not listed
in the rights just because the
constitution doesn't say you have the
right to run barefoot through sprinklers
on a hot summer day doesn't mean that
you don't have that right that's what
the ninth amendment says it says
government is not giving you freedom it
is simply listing a few of your freedoms
in the bill of rights
so
how have we come how have we come to the
point where today
you basically need to get government's
permission for
a wide variety of the things that you
spend your daily life doing think of the
things that you have to ask government
permission to do you need a permit to
build a house own a gun get a job buy
things sometimes run businesses pay your
your your employees even freedom of
speech now often comes with some sort of
permit requirement free we have these
colleges and and uh political
conventions setting up free speech zones
which are basically cages
where you're allowed to express your
opinion inside the cage as as the
popular saying has it i always thought
america was a free speech zone
but this is it's also a subtle sort of
thing you find it in places where you
wouldn't expect it an example that i use
in the book is architectural design
review
architectural design review occurs when
an architect comes has planned out maybe
a a a single building or a subdivision
and he goes before the city zoning board
and the city zoning board officials look
at it they say well it complies with all
of our safety codes but
i just don't like the way it looks i
would really prefer that it be colonial
or neo-colonial instead of whatever
other style it's designed in
purely for aesthetic reasons
i hold that architecture is a form of
sculpture it's an artistic expression
and therefore should be protected by the
first amendment as a form of free speech
in exactly the same way that other kinds
of sculptures are protected as free
speech
no one can walk through
a frank lloyd wright building or a
building by le corbusier or i'm from
pasadena a green and green uh uh
masterpiece like the the blacker house
in pasadena without experiencing the
aesthetic feelings that great artists
seek to convey it is a form of free
speech architectural design review
substitutes the government's aesthetic
preferences for the architect's own
unfortunately so far no architect has
been found with the guts to litigate
that point
what's happening in these and other
areas is that we're replacing the free
society with the permission society a
society where you are not free unless
the government gives you permission
now the model that lawyers use for this
that i describe in the book is the
difference between the nuisance system
and the permit system
the nuisance system is built on the
ancient classical legal principle sick
you tear a something something something
something i don't know that
and it what that means is you have the
right to use your property as you want
so long as you harm no other person
as opposed to the permit system which
says you are not allowed to do this
thing unless the government allows you
now there are problems with the nuisance
system one of the problems is that it's
it's basically reactive it allows people
to commit harms and then you can sue
them or or or get an injunction against
them more or less after they've
committed the harm or right immediately
before they're going to commit the harm
the permit system proposes to be
proactive it says no no you have to
prove to us that you are qualified
honest and so forth before you act
the problem is that there are many more
problems with the permit system than
with the nuisance system for example
rent seeking the phenomenon where if the
government can hand out benefits to
people it becomes in their best interest
to spend their time and money to get the
government to do that in their favor
another one is the knowledge problem
identified by friedrich hayek no
individual no corporation no government
can possibly know all of the information
necessary to run an entire economy the
classic example given by leonard reed is
the pencil nobody in the world knows how
to design how to build a pencil because
to build a pencil you need graphite and
wood to get the wood you have to have
lumber to get the lumber you have to
have lumberjacks to get lumberjacks you
have to feed them which means you have
to have farms which means you have to
write a few steps along this reasoning
and the entire world's economy is spent
building a single pencil
but the way it works is by a
decentralized process of decision making
that avoids this knowledge problem the
permit system
causes this knowledge problem so to take
an example in kentucky i litigated a
case in kentucky in defense of a of an
entrepreneur who wanted to start a
moving company and in kentucky as in
most states you're not allowed to start
a moving company until you first get
permission from all of the existing
moving companies in the state
not making this up this is the law in
about half the states and in most major
metropolitan areas it's called a
certificate of public convenience and
necessity law you have to prove to
government bureaucrats that there's a
need for a new moving company in
kentucky before they'll give you a
permit and any existing moving company
can object and say there's no need for
more competition against them
and guess what they often say that right
so we took we took this case to court
and in the deposition i asked how do you
how do you bureaucrats decide whether
there's a public need or even worse a
future public need for a moving company
somewhere down the line
and the the bureaucrat answering the
question said there are no objective
criteria well there you go that's
another problem with the permit system
is the vagueness of the criteria that
usually operate for instance in the gun
permit area you can't have a gun unless
there's good cause
what does good cause mean whatever the
bureaucrats say it means
but even deeper than this i think
there's even more fundamental problems
of the permit society one of them is it
violates the principle of equality
who has to ask permission
an inferior has to ask permission of a
superior
right
slaves have to ask permission children
have to ask permission until recently
women had to ask permission to own
property get jobs sign contracts and so
forth
right
to be in to have to ask permission from
someone else typically means flattering
or appeasing that person rather than
treating them as equal citizens or even
as government employees who stand
beneath the citizens in that sense
it substitutes political for economic
power the the permit system this
rent-seeking phenomenon creates a class
of people who have got access to the
government decision makers and can use
that power to benefit themselves the
soviet union called this the
nomenclatura system there was always a
class of people you know whose cousin
served on the board or whose brother was
on the committee or who you know in
exchange for a little something might be
able to get you some time in front of
the bureaucrat
that's another problem with the permit
system it allows those in power to
demand something in exchange for a
permit
in the land use context we often see
this where you apply for a permit to
build something the government comes
back and demands
property or even cash from you in
exchange for a permit the supreme court
has said that this is unconstitutional
in many cases but local land use
officials continue to do it nevertheless
i did a case in san diego in the san
diego area several years ago where my
client was forced to give up his right
to vote in exchange for a building
permit
but the most offensive part of the
permission system across the board is
how it deters innovation it restricts
opportunity simply by existing
think of this of an entrepreneur he
doesn't have a lot of capital comes up
with a great new idea a new innovation
he thinks wow you know this could really
help people and they'd be willing to pay
for it i could make a lot of money off
this and then he thinks of all the
permits he's going to have to get all
the hearings he's going to have to go
through maybe even special lobbying to
get a special law passed to exempt him
from an existing bureaucratic regime and
so forth and says to himself you know
it's just too much trouble
we can never assess that cost because it
vaporizes instantly it never comes into
existence
how much might have occurred how many
jobs might he be created how much wealth
might he have created and how many other
innovations would have come about
because of his innovation that also
vaporized in that instant as the great
poet john greenleaf whittier said
of all sad words of tongue or pen the
saddest are these it might have been
we never know what might have been if
there wasn't a government apparatus
barring innovation unless you can prove
to the government that there needs to be
a new business of that kind in that area
now for a year i've been a libertarian
since i was in high school
and
i remember how often i would say
something about freedom is good and the
answer would come back yes but you also
have to have responsibility and this is
often
uh the response that i get when i talk
about the problems of the permission
system the permission system is supposed
to impose responsibility the problem is
that responsibility can take two
different meanings it can either mean
don't hurt people
which is
sicutary something something something
that's the nuisance principle or it can
mean
do what we say
that's the permit system
i think the nuisance system is by and
large the better way to approach social
problems and that means presuming people
free unless they're going to harm some
other person
unfortunately i believe we are sliding
more and more into a society that
presumes you unfree unless you get the
government's permission and as we move
toward the permission society we're
moving away from the principles of
freedom upon which our constitution is
based
in 1946 at the nuremberg trials justice
robert jackson who was serving as the
prosecutor of the nazi war criminals was
looking for just the right way to
describe the freedom that he hoped would
rise from the ashes of europe and he
found those words in the poem by rudyard
kipling
all we have of freedom all we use or
know
this our fathers bought for us long and
long ago
ancient right unnoticed as the breath we
draw
leave to live by no man's leave
underneath the law
leave to live by no man's leave is the
essence of freedom
the more we're required to ask someone
for me for permission the more the
government presumes that we are not free
unless the government says we are the
less freedom that we have
and that's there's no reason for it it's
offensive and unjustified because in
fact we we accept the idea that people
are basically free through most of their
lives in fact most of the dangerous
things that we do in our lives driving
or eating we don't have to get the
government's permission before we do
those things
why can't we trust our fellow citizens
with freedom and if we can't trust them
with freedom whom can we trust with ours
thank you
well thank you very much tim
once again we are here to mark the
publication of tim's new book the
permission society which those in the
audience can purchase outside along with
tim's other books so please
feel free to do so and he'd be glad to
sign it for you while you were talking
tim um my colleague ilya shapiro sent an
email that just breaking news that your
circuit judge williams has
struck a
massive unchecked power of the consumer
bureau director
so
keep talking tim
all right now
to offer a um somewhat different
perspective perhaps uh we're going to
hear from an old friend of the cato
institute spoken here more than once uh
professor alan b morrison uh who is the
learner family associate dean
for public interest and public service
at george washington university school
of law
for most of his career dean morrison
worked for the public citizen litigation
group which he co-founded with ralph
nader in 1972
and directed for over 25 years his work
involved law reform litigation
in various areas including open
government
opening up the legal profession suing
agencies that failed to comply with the
law enforcing principles of separation
of powers protecting the rights of
consumers and protecting unrepresented
class members in class action
settlements
he's argued 20 cases in the supreme
court including victories in goldfarb
the virginia state bar holding lawyers
subject to the antitrust laws for using
minimum fee schedules virginia state
board of pharmacy for virginia citizens
consumer council making commercial
speech subject to the first amendment
fortunately
and insv chatter the very famous case
that struck down
over 200 federal laws containing the
legislative veto as a violation of
separation of powers
dean morrison currently teaches civil
procedure and constitutional law and
previously taught at harvard nyu
stanford hawaii and american university
law schools he's a member of the
american academy of appellate lawyers
and was its president in
1999-2000 he's a graduate of yale
university in the harvard law school he
served as a commissioned officer in the
u.s navy and was assistant u.s attorney
in new york please welcome alan morrison
thank you roger
the thesis of this uh new book is that
our society is inverted and that we need
permission uh instead of having the
freedom to do what we want to do
uh no doubt in my mind that permission
is needed for many things in society but
my reading of the book and knowledge of
society is that it's got it inverted
and that there's nowhere near the ratio
that the book's title and the book uh
would suggest in terms of permission
versus uh freedom
and uh as i thought about the few uh
stories of the book some of which are
very interesting and i agree with i i
remember that the old saying that uh the
plural of anecdote is not data uh and so
uh i thought i would start by a story of
my own uh about the real permission
society and it occurred when i was a
at the end of my first year in college i
was on a naval rotc cruise i love the
word cruz but it's it's what they called
it uh and it was very hot and i it was
at lunch time and i went down below and
got an ice cream and brought it up on
deck and
a person who outranked me which was
basically everybody uh came up to me and
said to me what are you doing with that
ice cream i said i'm eating it and he
said to me who told you you could eat
that ice cream here i said nobody
and he said i said nobody told me i
couldn't he said did anybody tell you
you could and that's when i knew the
difference between being in the navy and
being a civilian as a civilian i could
do anything i wanted unless somebody
told me i couldn't being in the navy i
couldn't do anything unless somebody
told me that i that i could so that
would be the true permission society
that i i envisioned it
but i don't find that to be the
permission society in in the world at
large today but let me start with a
couple of areas of agreement uh both
with respect to licensing and the
certificate of necessity um the first
time i ever uh had a matter with the
cato institute uh was back when the cato
institute was in a small town house on
first street northeast
and
i came over to talk to them about some
cases i had involved in the unauthorized
practice of law at the time i was
representing a legal secretary who was
being prosecuted by the florida state
bar for typing up divorce papers uh for
people who couldn't afford to have uh
lawyers and we had some challenges to
that and other similar activities and
cato was very much in line with us then
i had a lot of cases involving the legal
profession as you heard
many of them successful but
unfortunately in the area of
unauthorized practice of law i have been
largely unsuccessful
i had thought to try to bring cases in
that area uh raising a first amendment
challenge that after all uh rosemary
furman my client was just simply
speaking and writing and that was a
first amendment protected activity but
always thought that that was not a
winning argument uh that it was actually
conduct that people were were trying to
regulate
i didn't believe that i still don't
believe that all licensing of lawyers is
a bad idea it's just that they've gone
much too far in the areas in which only
lawyers are allowed
to provide the necessary services
the book talks about other licensing
among them the tour guides uh have to be
licensed
and and it's one thing to have them
licensed in the sense of having a bond
or or being able to identify them and
find out whether they have any criminal
activities uh but here in the district
of columbia i think it was your office
or maybe somebody else similar brought a
case involving the tour guides because
they had to take an examination of the
hundred most important monuments in the
city and be able to correctly identify
them less people would be misled
the case got to the dc circuit and uh it
eventually got settled uh by the
district wisely repealing that that
requirement uh but the tour guide rules
still apply in louisiana and other
places uh and
well could i envision some harm
occurring from from a misinformed tour
guide i suppose that i could the
question is is it serious enough to do
anything
about it
the trouble uh is
how do we deal with a problem like that
and the book proposes uh several tests
uh page 213 to suggest uh ways in which
the the licensing matters can be reduced
um uh for example there has to be a
genuine need clearly endangers the
public a tough analysis before passing
what do we do about the current laws
that are already on the books the
trouble with all those is if you ask the
legislators or the regulators they would
say they're already complying with them
they don't contend oh no we're not
regulating anything frivolous we're only
doing really important things and the
problem is how do you get a handle on on
that um
my own view is that the first amendment
is not the right way to go uh there have
to be better thing better ways to to
approach that uh problem
i suppose that we could have a situation
in which the federal trade commission
could come in given the authority to
preempt uh state and local regulations i
doubt that that would be a popular
solution here in this building but you
have to sometimes decide which is worse
uh licensing or not and the same is true
for the certificate of necessity
i personally encountered something the
other day
we tried our at gw to do a lot of pro
bono projects for our students and one
of the areas the students are
particularly interested in is helping
veterans uh with their problems
including their ability to get proper
pensions based on their disability and
an inability to perform any kind of work
at all after coming back from war zones
it turns out that
somebody in congress and i don't know
who it was has now got requirements in
there
that if in order to be
able to assist a person filing for
benefits you have to be accredited and
that applies whether you are a lawyer or
somebody else and if you are a lawyer
not only do you have to apply and be
accredited but you have to take three
hours of continuing legal education to
help a veteran file an application
and that nobody is allowed to do this
unless they are accredited uh
i thought that we were supposed to try
to help our veterans
and the danger of somebody
not helping them out as opposed to
having them have to do it themselves
seems to me to be completely misplaced
uh but and this is apparently a fairly
recent statute because all the veterans
organizations now have to get their own
persons accredited as as well
the second area that he talks about in
his book that i that i fully support him
in the certificate of necessity
i confess that i had not heard about
these moving company problems uh before
um certificates of necessity that i had
heard about involve for example the
ability of a hospital to open a new
place in a town where they were seeking
hillbert and funds to do so and in that
situation before the government spent
money they had to decide whether it was
necessary to do that or the same thing
is true with buying certain very
expensive
equipment but i have not heard about
this before
and i applaud the efforts to go after
those
i'm not sure the first amendment is the
right way to go after it i'm not sure
basic constitutional freedoms or or
substantive due processes the right way
but surely uh
the commerce clause uh ought to in these
interstate moving companies be a
fruitful ground for attack
i don't know how many of you have heard
about the problems that the tesla
automobile company has had in trying to
open up
new new markets
tesla had an idea that they wanted to
sell their cars directly to consumers a
number of states including virginia and
new jersey have laws that say you may
not sell cars unless you have a
dealership in our state that provides
full service and warranty to them
strikes me as being a plainly plain
violation of the commer dormant commerce
clause
that it plainly interferes with the
ability of interstate companies to do
business in the state it does not help
consumers at all there's nothing wrong
with the market for automobiles in this
regard that can't be cured
by
allowing tesla to come in if it does
business and provides proper service
people will know about it if it doesn't
people will know about it also
tesla tried to work with some of the
states for a while and now i i saw the
other day that they filed a lawsuit on
commerce clause grounds uh challenging
these laws as they properly uh should
when i saw the title to this book i
thought maybe this was going to be about
the fda and the epa but they're
surprisingly little uh in it
and uh
i i think that
that's a recognition uh that in our
permission society that the nuisance
theory only works so far
that we need some kinds of protections
in some cases and i don't understand
that tim disagrees i think the problem
is one of line drawing and how we decide
and who is going to decide uh which
areas need protection and which of them
uh don't uh
and and the more i thought about it the
the more i thought that the problem was
not in the generality uh but in weighing
the specifics um take the precautionary
principle which the book talks about
that's a general notion that uh if we
don't know about something new coming on
the market we uh and it has a potential
for being dangerous uh
pesticides for example or new drugs
all of which in order to do their work
must have side effects and the question
is are they meaningful are there harmful
side effects and does the drug do what
it's intended
to do the precautionary principle says
wait a second if we're not sure we
should perhaps
uh not allow something to go on the
market or put it on with with with uh
conditions uh including uh
post-marketing surveillance uh
and it's not
that
everybody who who concerned about this
thinks that we should either take
everything off the market or put it on
without conditions there are there are
interim positions and the question is
are those interim positions sensible i
really like the quote and i've used it
several times since then from saint
thomas aquinas uh thomas aquinas was
purported to have said he said if the
captain of the vessel were solely
concerned about the vessel safety he
would never leave port
and that's an interesting way of
thinking about it the point you made
earlier tim is that we don't know what
wouldn't have happened if we don't let
people go out
to sea on the other hand sometimes being
in port is not as safe as being out in
at anchor uh or or out perhaps even at
sea uh if we have a hurricane instead of
having your vessel smashed against
against the the dock sometimes it's
better to take a little risk and go out
uh to see
all right so as i was wondering about
this about the permissionless society i
thought about a recent phenomena
driverless cars
should
they have to get permits in order to be
out on the road are we willing to allow
the law of nuisance uh to decide whether
all of us are going to be
subject to having driverless cars or
should there be some kind of
restrictions permissions authorizations
checks
in advance and if so who should decide
and what should they they they be
the uh
uh
how about speed limits
is that a permission that we all should
be grant or we should be permitted to
drive as fast as as as as we want um or
what do we do about uber and airbnb uh
should they be regulated at all
and if so in what regard do we worry
about the interests of the workers who
are
subject to uh the conditions or should
we say they're they're all right we
don't have to worry about them they're
different from employees for whom we
have to worry about things like minimum
wage which you probably would be opposed
to in any event
and what do we do about the customers uh
there was a piece in the post a couple
weeks ago about uh racial discrimination
in airbnb uh if they're completely
unregulated uh what can we do about
about that
as well uh
the a book contains some early
references and praised for the decision
in in lochner
leaving aside the specifics of how the
bakers in that community got together
and passed the law that was only applied
to working
for bakers
the bigger question is
is it appropriate for our federal courts
to
essentially review
because they don't like
the economic regulation that has been
passed by our legislators or our
regulators
my own view is that the harms that come
from excessive economic regulation are
relatively modest
and that the danger of having the courts
step in and review
all economic and other regulation uh for
substantive due process violation is a
greater harm uh but that's my view and
it may not be that of everybody else in
the room
the last point i want to make is i was
rather surprised at who the enemy was in
this book
the enemy is the ruling class for which
i translate to be
elected and appointed officials
and the question is uh are we better off
or worse off with having democracy
because that's what we're talking about
there uh be be our guide in in these
areas
it is true of course in many cases we're
beset with regulatory and legislative
capture
and the book is clear however that that
doesn't occur in all the situations uh
the the question is how we try
to deal with that and how we try to draw
a better alliance
the book suggests that litigation may be
useful
not simply
as an opportunity to to turn back a bad
law
but as a means of exposing the silliness
behind the laws that we have
that it's a wonderful opportunity uh
when you when the government has to
answer your complaint uh they have to
put on a live witness who will say under
oath uh why they're doing what they're
doing uh and you get many answers that
are essentially indefensible uh all this
is part of a broader education program
and so whether litigation which i spent
much of my life doing is actually going
to win some cases that's nice and
important but it also serves a function
of reminding society that we all are
entitled to rational responses to the
questions that we ask thank you very
much
[Applause]
well thank you alan we've gone nearly
three quarters of an hour before lochner
came up which is a long time in this
auditorium
um we're now going to hear finally from
judge stephen williams who was appointed
to united states court of appeals in the
d.c circuit
in june
1986
and took senior status in september 2001
like dean morrison he's a graduate of
yale college and the harvard law school
he
was engaged in private practice from
1962 to 1966
and became an assistant u.s attorney for
the southern district of new york in
1966
from 1969 until his appointment to the
bench
judge williams taught at the university
of colorado school of law during this
time he also served as a visiting
professor of law at ucla
university of chicago law school and
southern
methodist university and he was a
consultant to the administrative
conference of the united states and the
federal trade commission
he's a noted expert on oil and gas law
and is the co-author of cases on oil and
gas law
which appeared in the sixth edition in
1992
his most recent
work is entitled liberal reform in an
illiberal regime 1906 to 1915 the
creation of private property in russia a
book that we featured here at the cato
institute when it came out and the book
that has been described by former acting
prime minister of russia igor gaidar as
absolutely splendid please welcome the
absolutely splendid judge stephen
williams
yeah
maybe there's one person who's deprived
of an opportunity to see me but he can
move
um i i thought the book was a generally
a very good assessment of the
pathologies of of regulation
but i don't think it's really consistent
with the uh norms of judicial ethics for
me to try to do either the equivalent of
what alan did or a rebuttal of what alan
said
uh we're not supposed to uh speak about
the about specific policy issues that
are likely to come up in front of us as
so many of these potentially could
but i do think that the what it is
useful for me to focus on
uh is the fundamental question of how
a permit system
actually differs from
regulatory systems
in which the government
acts after the citizen has acted
tim uses the metaphor nuisance systems
but i
i'll just call it non-permit systems
which are
are
cover a lot
um and
at the very end of the book
tim has a very brief section which he
enumerates
what he thinks are distinctive
drawbacks to a permit system
but i will argue that except for one
a very important one i hasten to say
except for one
they're ubiquitous across regulatory
systems
first rent seeking
uh that's undoubtedly present in permit
systems it's also present even in the
form of
after the fact regulation known as
antitrust law which i think is the is
the form of regulation probably most
uh most accepted by uh adherence of free
markets not not uniformly accepted but
nonetheless uh the most uh accepted
uh and as you know uh for a long time
not so much under current doctrine but
for a long time antitrust law was a
device by which uh people could take out
their competitors
ironically but in any event it worked
that way so renzi king was was at work
even there
tim identifies the knowledge problem
which to him is a an implicit claim
the government
has more or better knowledge than
private citizens first i would say
basically there's a lot of regulation
that really doesn't depend on that at
all
uh regulation depending upon the
proposition either the transaction costs
are too high for an optimal solution to
be worked out
by normal contract and property rights
or
asymmetries of information the drug
issue for example being a clear case of
of those
in any event
it's equally present
in non-permit systems
vagueness
well yes
uh both systems are vague i would argue
that the vagueness of a permit system is
slightly less dangerous than the
vagueness of a non-permit system in that
with a non-permit system the government
crashes down on you
after you've committed resources
possibly sends you to jail and so forth
because you misunderstood a particular
regulation
fourth demanding payoffs
yes and of course is his history of the
uh certificates of public convenience
and necessity which is a wonderful
chapter um
recounts many episodes of that but they
seem to function uh in non-permit
systems the the example that comes to my
mind most clearly
is the
situation where the government
believes that a bank has committed fraud
starts to investigate
and
of course the very fact of the
investigation
clouds the bank's prospects an
indictment would be fatal
let alone a conviction
uh the the recent deutsche bank uh
episode
uh suggests that he even even
rumors of an agreement on a settlement
can be nearly fatal to a bank
so again the uh
the need for payoffs which which result
from
the uh department of justice
criminal pursuits
[Music]
is present across the two systems
now i come to the one that i think is is
his strongest and i'll return to it
again
what he calls the double layer effect of
permits
and
he points out that
where the citizen proceeds without a
permit or in defiance of limits and a
permit
uh he's going to lose even if the denial
of the permit or its limitations were
illegal
so that certainly is a a double effect
and associated with that is the fact
that in the permit system
delay operates
against the citizen in favor of the
government citizen has to wait until the
government has finally pulled itself
together to act
i'll i want to
focus on that some more later
let me just quickly take the other two
uh objections that he poses stifling
innovation
surely true
in the case of after the fact regulation
again antitrust is a good example
finally the government as superior
well yes
these other systems involve
the government exercising its coercive
power
its monopoly on the use of
force to compel citizens to
to stop doing something or to pay a fine
for having done it
so i want to come back to the issue
of the essentially the delay coming at
the expense of the citizen actor
and i think the
the key problem there
uh is that
it and it means that the
uh
adverse effects of the regulatory system
uh tend to be hidden
so compare a system of
regulation of truckers
uh under which you have to get a permit
to go into the business
or
you can be
fined or imprisoned by the government
if you enter the business
and the government finds that your
activities have an adverse effect on the
economic prosperity of the
truckers pre-existing truckers with whom
you compete
imagine a
someone uh who thinks he'd like to go
into trucking and under the
second system the government government
is going to clamp down on you afterwards
he buys a truck he starts providing
services
maybe he starts to get pretty good at it
or pretty successful he gets a second
truck a third truck
he has by this time
quite a few customers
maybe a little reputation
at that point
uh the pre-existing competitors asked
the government agency hey you got to
move against this guy he's clearly
violating the norm which is probably
true
uh and they go after him
i think in that in that context
their ability to get the result they
like
is going to be weaker
than in the permit system because by
this time people know about it he's got
if he's done even a decent job and if he
hasn't done a decent job he's probably
gonna the
business will die on its own
um
if if he's if he's done a decent job
people will be upset there might there
should be i would hope news coverage uh
of the government's attacking this
person
and uh he has a
i would say a far better chance
of escaping the regulatory
nemesis
uh than he would
uh under the permit system
alan brought up uber
um
and
one of my this is entirely speculative
but
uh uber by the time it became
controversial
had a lot of customers
uh who were
many of them really quite um
you know
they were members of the elite put it
simply
uh and i think that has made it harder
it means that the
uh
taxicab companies whose
uh
entitlements are jeopardized by uber
are in a much weaker position to oppose
it than they would have been before some
agency uh regulating its services at the
outset
now the the concept of prior restraint
comes from the from
free speech
uh and consider it there i think you
have the same the same situation
um
if a person can publish first
and and a premise is going to be
that there is a modicum of free speech
in this hypothetical society
if you can publish first
then
people when the government goes after
you
people quite a few people presumably
will know what it is you were saying
and
95 of the time
uh government going after you
on the grounds of what you said is going
to look extraordinarily silly whereas if
they simply cut it off in a censorship
program
nobody essentially would know about it
so that that now
the modicum of free speech is important
in stalin's russia i don't think it
would make any difference
whether a permit system was used or just
the nkvd coming after you it works
exactly the same
but that's because there was no way in
which
publications
uh
that didn't represent the party line
could actually go ahead
um
basically the proposition is one of
strangling things in their cradle
and and tim's book brought to mind a
favorite poem of mine grey's elegy in a
country church yard which is all about
uh people whose
uh potential is never realized this is a
nice allusion to some mute and glorious
milton here may rest that goes on and on
in that vein
and a trucker may not seem the
equivalent of milton presumably is not
but i think when we recognize the
creativity that is associated with
entrepreneurship in general
um
you see the the
uh message
from gray's elegy uh is really
uh manifest and becomes important uh
where a permit system is used i should
add one thing though i
it seems to me
clear that in certain cases
the regulati is going to vastly prefer
a permit system suppose you're about to
set up a line of
uh production of cars
that you know have to meet some criteria
for
uh emissions
of knox and so forth
you want to know
before you spend 100 million 200 million
dollars on your production line
that you're not going to have trouble on
the technology that you use in that
in the car that you produce on this
production line
so
that is at least an instance where
a a permit system is to the advantage of
the permittee i have some other thoughts
but maybe you got a chance in the
discussion to work them in
well i i want to begin by saying how
happy i am at the number of poets who
have been mentioned in this conference i
think i i count four and i think we
should make it a rule that cato should
ensure that at least three poets are
quoted in every presentation um i only
have a brief period so i want to say i
think a lot of these comments are are so
intelligent and deep that they would
require a much more thorough
discussion which is why i wrote a whole
book in response to
and actually other books i noticed some
of the references for instance uh dean
morrison said that the the enemy is
democracy um i don't think that's quite
accurate but to discuss my views on that
question you should consult my last book
the conscience of the constitution that
discusses um the dangers of democracy
and so forth i will add though that
administrative agencies that typically
enforce these permit requirements are
the least democratic thing you can
imagine they're not staffed by elected
officials most of the laws under which
you live your life are imposed not by
elected officials but by unelected hired
bureaucrats in administrative agencies
that cannot even be fired because
they're government union members
the basic thesis of my book is that the
idea of prior restraint should apply to
all permit systems regardless of subject
the supreme court said in the 50s that
there's basically three rules for when a
prior restraint is acceptable and that
is there must be a time limit within
which the permit will be granted or
denied there must be clear unambiguous
criteria for the granting or the denial
of the permit not vague standards like
good cause and there should be a right
to real judicial review if you're
wrongly denied the permit not some sort
of fake review in an administrative
hearing where the prosecutor is paying
the judge my argument is basically that
those principles should be applied
across the board to all kinds of permit
and licensing requirements
with regard to
licensing i address this in my 2010 book
right to earn a living
and
i explained that i agree that i think
first the first amendment is not exactly
not always the best route to go that way
the right route is substantive due
process unfortunately that doctrine
which is the oldest and most important
of all constitutional protections in
western civilization has been largely
undermined by both left and right um
fortunately we at the goldwater
institute have a solution for these
problems
one of them is our right to earn a
living act which is legislation that
would require state courts to impose a
higher level of review than rational
basis when it comes to legal challenges
to restrictions on economic liberty
because you know
dean morrison is right that when i
address the tests that ought to be
applied
to whether a permit requirement is valid
or not that gets a little bit vague but
the reason for that is because at
present under the rational basis test
it's basically anything goes the
government wants to impose a restriction
on economic liberty it's basically free
to do so at will the right to earn a
living act when enacted would require
courts to ensure that restrictions on
economic liberty directly protect public
safety and are no broader than necessary
um when it comes to the fda our right to
try legislation which is now law in 32
states is a first step toward
rationalizing the currently irrational
process of drug development and approval
by the federal food and drug
administration a process that takes as
much as a decade in a billion dollars to
approve medicines that could save
people's lives the right to earn a
living act allows people who are
terminally ill to use medicines that
have been approved for basic safety but
are not yet fully approved for sale uh
by the fda as far as certificate of need
laws those also would be uh the right to
earn a living act i think would resolve
that problem keep in mind though that
we're not not talking about intra-state
certificate of need laws those were
largely abolished in the eighties um
it's tr it's intra state it's within the
state that's the problem and that can
only be addressed by legal reform or by
courts taking seriously the protections
of the 14th amendment that prohibit the
government from arbitrarily denying
people their economic liberty
um i think judge williams has a good
point that really the the question is
between reactive and proactive or
between prior restraint versus
punishment afterwards
and it's true that you will encounter a
lot of similar problems in punishment
afterwards that you would encounter in
prior restraint that's also true in
speech right lawyers have had a long
debate since the constitution was
written over how much further the first
amendment goes
then the old rule against prior
restraints everybody seems to agree that
the old rule against well everybody
except the supreme court seems to agree
that the old rule against prior
restraints is part of the first
amendment
for prior restraints are never allowed
the supreme court says except when right
uh one thinks of the passage in in the
animal farm when the animals emerge to
find that that no animal shall drink has
been changed to no animals shall drink
to excess
uh no prior restraint to excess is what
the supreme court now says but in any
case
part of that debate between proactive
and reactive is well can you really
punish a person after they speak is that
okay under the first amendment amazingly
early federalists the adams
administration said yes it's okay to
punish people after they speak for the
words that they utter and courts have
developed doctrines that allow
in some cases like libel or threats but
for the most part protect free speech i
think if the same vigilance were applied
when it comes to economic liberty and
the other issues that i talk about we
would be in a better state than we are
now in
that's why my book doesn't try to draw
easy lines and say here's a
clean solution to this problem because i
do agree that there are cases i think
rare cases when a prior restraint rule
is appropriate
but they have to fall under those three
criteria specific timelines for the
grant and denial clear criteria for the
granting or denial and judicial review
if you're wrongly denied before they can
be even considered appropriate
thank you very much we look forward to
your questions
all right well thank you very much tim
um
do we have any
short discussion here on the okay let's
open it up to your questions please uh
wait for a microphone to get to you uh
identify yourself in any affiliation
that you may have uh as i'm sending one
person on one aisle i'll send another
person on another aisle so that we can
get in as many questions as possible and
please ask a question don't give a
speech
and let's uh begin with um where do i
this gentleman right here
hi michael enters washington d.c
i work in the field of mental health and
hold a number of licenses to do that
in the various local jurisdictions one
of the things that is involved in
getting those licenses
are a number of prerequisites
and it's been my belief for some time
that the prerequisites were an
expression of the government's inability
to devise a test
that accurately measured whether or not
somebody should be allowed to practice
the profession
and i just wanted to comment on that
well i'll say i have a whole passage in
the book in which i argue that
psychologist licensing should be
abolished across the board
psychology is nothing more than talking
as opposed to psychiatry which includes
prescribing medicine psychology is a
talking cure and it is in principle no
different than the discussions that go
on between a penitent and his priest
between myself and my mother between
myself and my best friend between people
you know people
talk about their problems and when you
look at the statutes for the legal
definitions of psychology that's what
you find is you find these terms very
broad things like helping people with
their human problems
does that satisfy the void against
vagueness criteria holy cow right so and
and if it's the answer typically comes
well yes but you're dealing with
depressed people who might kill
themselves if you give them bad advice
but the same could also be said of
conversations with my mother and with um
that just kidding just kidding
kidding
that's true of of conversations with the
priests and so forth and that's why
these laws are riddled with exceptions
that say they don't apply to members of
the clergy they don't apply lawyers can
practice psychology did you know this
i'm a licensed attorney so i can
practice psychology i guarantee you i
have no expertise in psychology so i
think that those kinds of rules should
be completely abolished and i not only
is it that these these standards reflect
the government's inability to come up
with precise standards but that variant
ability gives an opportunity for rent
seeking by those who already have
licenses to prohibit competition against
them
and and that's the real problem i think
isn't the
use of prerequisites
by the state that they haven't been able
to come up with them
i think in some cases it can be
yeah okay again let me see your hands so
we can send you okay the next one is
just gentlemen right over here and go
ahead right here first
then here
uh joel m
joel mandelman i'm an attorney in
washington
coming back to the psychologist isn't it
sufficient to say that you must have at
least a master's degree or a phd
as a prerequisite that doesn't involve a
lot of government regulation but
nevertheless protects
somebody who's got
admitted mental problems that wouldn't
be there
from being injured and second
my understanding is in a number of
states
psychologists have
gotten or are actively trying to get the
right to prescribe medicines to patients
uh just the way a psychiatrist would so
doesn't that begin to weaken your
sort of the second part of your argument
well if the profession is different then
the criteria should be different i would
favor something that says you have to
have a master's degree
period over something that's more vague
like well you have to prove that you're
skilled and competent or something like
that um i guess it's just a question of
how much of camel's nose are you willing
to accept under the tent uh and and you
find problems like the case i discussed
in the book in which a a columnist a
newspaper advice columnist was
prosecuted for practicing psychology
without a license he was a licensed
psychologist in his home state but
because his column ran in another state
where he didn't have a license he was
prosecuted for this um i think it goes
without saying that
the licensing of advice columns is not
compatible with the first amendment the
america's first advice calmness of
course is benjamin franklin who never
went to college although he was called
dr franklin he did not have a doctorate
uh and he often made up the questions
that he answered in his newspaper he
didn't i think it would have been
inconceivable to the founders that the
first amendment would authorize a
licensing requirement in that regard
with regard to medicine you know the the
medicine rules are a form of permit
requirement for possessing medicine as a
libertarian i'm fine with all of it
being legal but if there is going to be
restriction it needs to be as
unambiguous and as as uh fairly enforced
as possible
uh the in the the kentucky doctor
ultimately won his case
uh in a decision by the federal district
court helen you were to come in well uh
the advice column reminded me when i
taught
professional ethics at law schools i
used to use ann landers uh her advice
columns about giving legal advice
somebody would write
can i do this and such and such what
happens if this and she would give the
advice and so i would ask my students
is she practicing law without a license
and if so in what jurisdiction
the other thing i want to say is that
there's an interim position on the
psychologist and that is a certificate
which says if you have a certificate in
order to say that you're psycho
have a certificate and that has some
objective criteria you've taken the
following courses and so forth and if
you don't have a certificate you could
practice anyway but it's a sort of an
indication of that you're more qualified
than i would be for example i i'm
embarrassed to say i forgot to to
discuss that there are private market
alternatives to government licensing and
regulation that are all almost
invariably preferable um when i go to a
restaurant i don't look up their
licensing history with the department of
health i look them up on yelp i ask my
friends who went to that restaurant my
friend says they don't go there i got
the stomach flu then i don't go there
right that's what most people do with
their life uber provides a rating system
for their drivers which is not really
provided in any effective way by any
taxi regulatory agency except in
competition with uber now
so i think there are alternatives
available on the private market and keep
in mind that the supreme court in the
playboy enterprises case
looked to the availability of private
market alternatives as part of its
narrow tailoring analysis as part of the
question of whether there were least
less restrictive means available i think
that time has come for us to push that
point and say if there are private
market market alternatives to government
regulation then that means this
regulation is broader than necessary
well alan would it make a difference
with this psychologist that you just
spoke enough if uh the
advice were given free rather than
commercially
well of course uh
that didn't make a difference in the
unauthorized practice of law rules it's
quite clear that it doesn't matter
whether you're giving out free advice uh
and the same is true in medicine uh
subject of course to the to your uh
mother's exception for telling you to
take some aspirin and go to bed
so so if your non-lawyer brother-in-law
gives you legal advice he's guilty of
practicing law without a license
yes uh of course somebody has to notice
notify the authorities out or they have
to decide whether they're gonna they're
gonna come after you but technically yes
that's right
and this is an important point because i
talk in the book there this legal
doctrine of professional speech that
where the government can regulate what
professionals tell their their clients
more directly than it can regulate other
kinds of speech a doctrine that not only
has never been discussed by the supreme
court never been endorsed by the supreme
court united states but has never even
really been discussed in a single
majority opinion in the history of the
united states supreme court and yet
lower courts have adopted this doctrine
that says that that
a government official an elected
legislator who has no expertise at all
in psychology or whatever the profession
might be is in a better position to tell
a doctor what he can tell his patient
than i am i that that doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
well sir
i'm
roger the university of oxford um i just
wonder if you're being a little bit too
dependent on freedom because the
american farmers were very conscious
that they were appealing to natural law
and john locker whom they uh depended uh
had very definitely a lot of abuses like
our god-given nature of our feet so
actually these are doctrines about human
nature and what humans everywhere not
just about what happens in the united
states so you are actually appealing to
something that's a fundamental
importance to everyone everywhere and
too much emphasis on madison team seems
to restrict that i think well if that's
the message i gave i am gravely sorry
because of course the doctrines of of
human liberty that the founders endorsed
are doctrines that are always true for
all people everywhere and i would be
ashamed of myself if i had said anything
if i said anything that was narrower
than that
steve wants to follow up i just wanted
to uh underscore that this was
spurred in my mind by tim's reference to
magna carta i thought he unduly slighted
magna carta
because it fairly explicitly
purports to represent the continuation
of ancient liberties
which i think and and then when you see
it under uh coke that that seems in
effect to be something very akin to
natural law
so um
i
the uh
the source of these liberties
is complicated it doesn't mention doctor
coke in dr bonham's case was one
involving the
licensure requirements of the city of
london with respect to a doctor i i am a
great admirer of lord cook he's he is uh
the greatest lawyer of all time what he
said about magna carta i think is not
really what magna carta says but i
believe there was a decision from the
court of kings bench in the 1910s that
said lord cook was such a great lawyer
that even his mistakes are the common
law so
uh up here please
i i just found out that you wrote the
new book on baseball did you speak up a
little bit yes i can hear me now yeah
the question is just about your book
what are some of the good um either
results or outcomes that you found in
your research that we can say we can
actually practice this i think it's a
good theory but i wasn't kind of clear
in terms of what you discussed with us
and how to actually
implement that in terms of understanding
just what getting permission is all
about from your perspective
well the the thesis of my book is that
we typically shouldn't be required to
ask permission in the first place now i
i actually found so many
positive outcomes as i was putting
together the examples that i sort of had
a hard time finding negative examples um
because a lot of the time these people
take on these cases and win them the the
the psychologist who is writing the
newspaper column for example he ended up
winning his case now that is because
the in his case the institute for
justice but other organizations that
will represent people for free were they
were willing to take on that case we can
never really know how many people would
have been scared away by a threatening
letter from the kentucky department of
psychology licensing so we don't really
know whether the outcomes are all good
or bad and it's impossible to do
empirical research of that sort um but
no i i give a lot of good of positive
examples of how in the end so people
have taken on this system and won and of
course i'm in the business of taking on
the system and i hope winning so i'm ra
rod let's let's take this problem on but
it is a real problem the louisiana
florist did lose they did in louisiana
you have to have a license to be a
florist and at the time that that case
went on you were graded on the beauty of
your floral designs for example well you
might get a bad floral arrangement and
you know we have to protect customers
from that
sounds right he's not making that up
he didn't do it
uh did we this gentleman right up here
and then this gentleman right here yes
i'm an endangered and endangered species
at the fcc and now uh three times your
honor at the d.c circuit uh i'm an
entrepreneur uh and um professor uh it
occurs to me that an imprimatur was
required from the curia
saint dominic and the holy father
and if it wasn't obtained the
consequence could have been significant
so i think a little bit of latin here in
numero veritas do you agree professor
that to draw the line
uh benefit cost is a way to go if if
regulation is potentially
desirable or not
and that too little of it is done in uh
in the article two agencies
and your honor regarding
seeking
forgiveness rather than permission don't
you think the cost of capital is a
self-regulating
factor
if the risk of not getting permission up
front is
and getting punished later is very high
the cost of capital can self-regulate
that for an enterprise or an
entrepreneur thank you
a good point i have a very quick you
probably haven't i don't know i i i
don't see i i can see how the cost of
capital makes
a uh a permit system
increases the ways in which permit
system is preferable
in my example of the automobile
manufacturer
but i'm not sure how that
it's self-regulating in the sense that
that cost of capital
is
brought to bear on our legislators when
they're deciding between different
approaches
risk punishment is very high
fair to get permission
can't raise capital get the risk of um
yeah but the system has to be set up to
allow that
i'll try to answer the question i'm not
quite sure that i understood the
question uh if if the question is do our
agencies take costs into account in a
proper way
the answer is
i think so but i'm not sure uh and uh i
don't know how i would be able to
measure whether they did it properly or
not other than the fact that we we have
judicial review at various times and we
have political review
and if you're not sure
how why is it you're
confident that the agency is able to
take these into consideration
able or does or does properly uh
probably probably willing more than able
well i i don't know i think some
agencies are more willing in some
circumstances in some administrations
than they are and others uh and some of
them are are instructed to take safety
into account and they may or may not
take safety into account in some
administrations in some situations and
not another so uh well the epa is
notorious well open that regard sir even
sure a question from mr sanderfurb would
you have taken on the defense of adam
and eve after they were expelled from
the garden of eden for eating the
forbidden fruit
well i'm delighted to have a milton
reference to go with our other well no
milton was one of the four i already
counted uh he's my favorite christian
libertarian and if none of you have read
paradise lost i urge you to do so it's
one of my favorites although as dr
johnson said no man ever wished it
longer
um
but it is i i think the i think milton
gives the best possible defense of adam
and eve especially adam who chooses to
eat the apple and live in a fallen world
rather than live without eve which is
the most beautiful love poem i i've ever
read
well of course it's the snake who needs
some representation as twain said we we
only have one side of that story right
that's right because after all he got a
bum rap it's the the sin is not in the
tempting the sin is in succumbing to the
temptation
well it was free speech and that's a
lesson for corrupt
and that's a lesson for corruption of
political officials as well it's not in
the tempting it's in the succumbing to
it which many a political operative has
done all the way in the back we have a
hand up if you could run right back
there any other hands let's see them
uh yes devin uh
i'm george messenger i'm a high school
senior at the heights school in potomac
maryland
and there was some discussion of due
process and i'm writing my senior thesis
on uh this state of freedom of speech
and the first amendment in universities
particularly public universities and i
was wondering if you could comment on
the state of free speech in public
universities and particularly uh denied
due process
yes well i have a section in the book in
which i make an analogy between the
recently enacted yes means yes law in
california and the permission society as
a form of permit requirement to for sex
um where you are presumed a rapist
unless you can prove afterwards that you
got consent from your partner at every
stage and that she did not revoke it
afterwards um which is a plain violation
of due process undermines the most basic
principle not just of our criminal law
but of epistemology itself which is that
who asserts the claim must prove it
that's the origin of our principle of
innocent until proven guilty and the
reason for it is not a preference of
just an arbitrary preference of our
society it's it's written into the laws
of logic that it's impossible to
disprove something truly and therefore
it is it makes no sense to put the
burden of proof on the defendant to
prove that he did not commit the crime
so i think that is a real problem with
regard to free speech i i have to admit
i am astonished by what is going on on
these university and college campuses
nowadays i did not see this coming i i
am amazed by the degree to which it
seems that schools are cracking down on
unpopular thought it's a it's a disgrace
in a country that not only prides itself
on freedom but that has long prided
itself on training its rising generation
to cherish and protect the principles of
freedom right as reagan said we defend
frida freedom here or it is gone and if
we don't defend it then we must tell our
grandchildren what it was that we found
more precious than freedom
um so it is it's disgraceful that we are
facing a situation where where even the
most innocent remark or a halloween
costume can get people in serious
trouble with universities that are after
all government entities and have a
constitutional obligation to accord due
process rights to students before
punishing them um i escaped that by
going to a college that receives no
government funding hillsdale college um
although they also have disciplinary
restrictions on free speech but um in
any event i think it's a shame and i
don't talk about it at
that part at great length in the book
well even in private schools there are
contractual remedies that are often
invoked by such organizations as fire
the foundation for individual rights in
education and you can go to my website
at cato and find two long speeches on
the subject of free speech in academia
tim is absolutely right what is going on
today is very different from back in the
60s when the students were clamoring for
free speech as in berkeley california
today it's the students who are
clamoring for safety and for
it's the cry bullies as it is who want
to be sheltered from anything that makes
them uncomfortable and a lot of a lot of
people are familiar with fire's
excellent work but uh let me put in a
word for another favorite organization
the student press law center which i've
been a great fan of for for many years
yeah so where did the oh devin the next
question uh anymore hands up evan
watkins at the cato institute uh i had a
question about the extent of government
powers without crossing that line of
asking for permission so the first would
be a registration requirement whether
you don't ask permission but you're
required to inform the government before
you do it and the second would be some
type of requirement to post a bond so
that afterwards if we find you violated
the rules we have some way of punishing
someone that has no money
and the last would be in a case where we
do switch to a permissionless system say
the government writes very vague
regulations and then allows you to ask
the government whether such and such a
thing would violate the law in advance
and kind of gives you a safe harbor if
they say that it would would you perhaps
be going into many of the same problems
in such a system like that
i'll let the other panels go first so
they like well
the burden of my remarks was that you
would
yes
that that uh all that
uh i mean you're right i think to
identify continuum in terms of degree of
advance
review
but
most of the problems that tim identifies
and associates with the permit system
apply across the board so i think in
partial responses that the question is
what is the substantive standard under
which you can either be granted or
denied a permit or be punished or have
some uh something happen to you
afterwards and it's the difficulty in
designing
words that will express
good it doesn't
tim doesn't like good cause uh
but the problem is trying to find
something else in various circumstances
that will work in the context of the
particular regulation good cause means
something quite different for firearms
than it does for whether somebody could
be discharged
yeah i think um
so in my perfect world i wave my wand
and i get rid of the permission society
there still are something very similar
to permit requirements and that is
primarily done by insurance companies so
if i'm gonna start a business i need to
get insurance in case the place burns
down the insurance company comes to me
and says well okay we'll insure you but
you have to you have to show us that
you've built your house out of fireproof
or about your business out of fireproof
materials or something like that and i
think in fact historically government
often looks to the criteria that were
first invented by insurance companies in
order to adopt its own criteria that it
then imposes in the form of building
permits requirements and things so
that would be my solution that i think
there are market alternatives and the
benefit to them is that they're more
flexible uh you know the take zoning for
example zoning was supposed to be 100
years ago and zoning was invented zoning
was going to be rational land use
planning we won't have the pig in the
parlor as justice sutherland said we're
going to have we're going to have the
businesses over here and the residences
over there now first of all it was
immediately captured by through rent
seeking by uh by people who wanted to
exclude racial minorities from white
neighborhoods and it was used to to
block that from happening which of
course still goes on just subtly um and
the uh the if you look at the look at
the the zoning map of manhattan today it
is every bit as crazy quilt as it ever
was a century ago except there is this
difference that the all the exemptions
and grandfathering in and excuses and
different and all these different rules
those have all been triggered by
political decision making instead of by
the economic decision making of the
people who want to use the property and
consumers and the supply and demand
instead it's based on whether you know
somebody at city hall whether you can
persuade city hall to give you an
exemption and that sort of thing
and of course the use of insurance
companies especially in a competitive
insurance market allows for cost benefit
analysis to be brought in in a rational
way that
unfortunately agencies uh are less able
this is why roger has two people on that
side and one person on this because he
can't resist uh helping me
and he's absolutely right well
not that you need it
[Laughter]
when you do all come to the rescue we've
got time for one more question all the
way in the back bonner
bonner core national center for public
policy research mr sanderfer uh could
you hold the microphone closer to you uh
how's that that's good okay uh barnacle
our national center for public policy
research mr sanderfer dean morrison uh
referenced your use of the term ruling
class
but he seemed unclear as to what you
meant by it so could you tell us briefly
what you meant by the ruling class were
you referring to something similar to
what angela kodavilla wrote about in a
in his essay a few years ago did you
clear that up for us thank you
uh well i guess it sort of has some
parallels but the um no what i mean is
that when you have a system as i said
when you have a permission system you
have to look up at superiors and ask for
their permission to do your thing well
those superiors that what happens is
over time
those that gets uh coalesces into a
permanent over class
and the people who have to ask
permission coalesce into a permanent
underclass a great example this is the
moving case right the kentucky wouldn't
allow new competition in the moving
industry but existing industry existing
movering companies could sell or give
their licenses to others so typically
they gave or sold them to friends and
family members and so gradually what you
see happening is there's a class of
people who have licenses and a class of
people who don't and the more the system
turns into a permission requirement the
more separated and rigid those class
distinctions become and so i think what
happens is over time those tend to
polarize around racial distinctions
around distinctions based on
socioeconomic status from the beginning
point and if this malady continues to
worsen what you end up with is something
like the old regime of france uh that's
for you jason uh or for the the uh
18th century england where you
it rigidly coalesces into guilds who
have insider status and those of us who
don't and the one of the great
revolutions of the 18th century was to
break that system down if you jefferson
talks in summary view of the rights of
british america the pamphlet that got
him the job writing the declaration of
independence he talks about economic
liberty he says it's illegal for the
colonists to make things out of iron at
that time the colonists were required to
to send the iron to britain to be made
into consumer goods and then shipped
back to the colonies for use why he says
to protect not men but machines in the
island of great britain what he means is
this class of people who have political
protection so that they don't have to
compete fairly and the great idea of our
economic system is that we shouldn't
have those classes it should be up to
personal merit and hard work and there's
another old world the old word that
captures this um regime of the ruling
class that extends well beyond the um
the government officials and it's called
syndicalism yeah right remember that one
i always think of the star bellied
sneetches from dr seuss
they have stars on their bellies and we
don't and that system gets worse and
worse over time
um again the permission society is the
book that we're here to
note
and please
avail yourself of the opportunity to
pick up a copy outside tim will be glad
to sign it for you as long as as well as
his other books
also i want to again thank the
federalist society for their
co-sponsorship of this program i want to
thank c-span and its audience for
joining us in this program and let's now
head up to the george m yeager
conference center for lunch and before
we do give a while
warm round of applause
[Applause]
um